you may have heard that UPS isn't quite
the [ __ ] fight with FedEx although
they're both package delivery companies
they're governed by totally different
federal labor rules UPS is business is
mostly tied to trucking so it falls
under the National Labor Relations Act
which makes it easy for workers to
unionize FedEx delivers most of its
packages by airplanes so it falls under
a different set of rules that makes it
tougher for FedEx employees to unionize
the result is that UPS is labor costs
are more than double fedexes now UPS and
its unions are pushing to change FedEx
is federal labor status to the same as
UPS the Teamsters alone gave 2.4 million
dollars to Democrats in the 2008
election cycle and they want rules that
will make it easier for unions to
organize in the private sector where
unions have dropped from representing a
high of 36 percent of workers to just 7%
today unions are the legacy of the
Industrial Revolution of an assembly
line mentality that treated all workers
as interchangeable the main reason
they've lost ground over the past 60
years is because work is increasingly
individualized and so is compensation
the move to screw over FedEx and its
customers is contemptible but it does
make a sick sort of business sense why
not use legislation to win what you can
in the marketplace and it tells us who
the real villain is here
a federal government that is big enough
and powerful enough to absolutely
positively guarantee that it can crush
any business overnight oh look there's
the package deliveries are